au moment des événements c'était on
venait tout juste de commencer notre
caucus notre réunion de cocu ce qu'on
fait à tous les mercredis matin tous les
partis font ça dans l'édifice du
parlement et tout à coup on a entendu
des bruits de plusieurs bruits en ce
moment sur la colline du parlement à
cause des rénovations au début on s'est
pas inquiété nécessairement les
premières secondes le tout à coup on a
entendu des coups de feu qui se
rapprochait très très rapidement de nos
salles le caucus donc tout s'est passé
extrêmement vite
assuré de sécuriser les portes le plus
rapidement possible et tout le monde
sait c'est caché en dessous des chaises
des tables qui avait dans notre salle
donc c'était un peu irréel
certainement la première chose que j'ai
pensé c'est est-ce que j'ai mon
téléphone près pour pouvoir contacter
mon conjoint pression qu'ils soient
correctes que ma fille soit en sécurité
que lui soient en sécurité parce que
votre fille elle est dans la garderie du
parlement à ce moment là exactement à
quelques centaines de mètres où est ce
que les ou est-ce que la fusillade a eu
lieu sur la colline parlementaire à ma
fille était à la garderie donc la
première partie du jury s'était de
penser d'être certaine que ma famille
est en sécurité ça a été des très grands
minutes d'angoissé parce qu'il fallait
rester en silence caché sous les tables
l'on revoit encore ces images on entend
ces coups de feu ça devait être quand
même assez vous disais sur réel comme
dans un film un peu oui c'était
c'est quelque chose qu'on voit à la télé
à laquelle on ne s'attend pas à
avez-vous dans une situation de travail
surtout avec une équipe de constable une
équipe de grc sur la colline
parlementaire qui sont absolument
incroyable en fait un travail très très
rapide pour sécuriser le périmètre donc
on s'est sentis automatiquement sécurité
mais c'est sûr que les premières minutes
d'angoissé qu'on me dit qu'il fallait
sortir rapidement des salles courir en
silence pour se mettre en lieu sûr
et
à un moment donné dans la journée vous
avez dû être soulagé quand vous avez
appris que le tireur était avaient été
abattues j'étais surtout été soulagés de
voir que l'équipe tactique la grc
constable ont fait un travail très très
rapide et puis qui ont tout fait pour
nous mettre en sécurité sur la colline
parlementaire ça s'est fait très
rapidement nous on a été escorté un
petit groupe de députés à l'extérieur du
parlement
on a tous été placés à des endroits
différents et on a vu toutes les équipes
d'intervention arrivé en ce sens
extrêmement sécurité l'a ensuite les
hordes attendre se sont passées où
est-ce qu'on avait plusieurs
informations soulager en fait que c'est
un événement là soit derrière et
qu'est-il arrivé à votre chef thomas
mulcair il a été vous avez été séparée
de lui à ce moment là oui en fait les
informations qui sont à ma disposition
c'est qu'on lui a offert de quitter
l'édifice du centre
dans les minutes qui ont suivi
l'événement mais il a décidé de rester
avec la majorité des députés qui étaient
présents pour s'assurer que tout le
monde était en sécurité son bureau est
au est directement les tissus sans qu on
a une grosse équipe
avec avec le chef de l'opposition
officielle qui sont présents sur place
et s'est assuré que tout le monde était
en sécurité avant de pouvoir se déplacer
qu'est ce que vous allez retenir de
cette journée qu'est-ce qu'il vous
restait beaucoup de choses qui vont me
restait en tête je crois que le
parlement sera probablement plus ce
qu'il était j'espère qu'on va pouvoir
continuer à travailler je trouve ça
triste qu'on est
con et brimer la démocratie comme
cependant pendant une journée entière
puis je peux confirmer le sentiment pas
je veux qu'on retienne que aujourd'hui
on a vu que les canadiens étaient
solidaires face à cet événement là on a
reçu beaucoup de messages d'espoir et
d'amour qu'ils ont été envoyés soit
qu'il faut retenir de cet événement le
concerne tous solidaires ensemble